have you heard of um sock coin sock yeah
like the sock no like uh like sock on
these
nuts we're coming baby sh Anthony this
guy's a little too masculine for
[Music]
me so the much awaited for Bitcoin ETF
has been approved W which is why it's
dipping it pumped all the way to like we
got scoop pum to 49 look the
announcement was priced in right it it
was priced in it doesn't matter it's
about what's coming right so the all the
money all the billions of dollars that
are going to come into the space it's
going to come yeah he likes that um
that's what that's what's important
about this right $4 billion worth the
tradeing the first day first day yes and
now it's look like most things when
Facebook came out Facebook dumped the
first four months right and everyone's
like ha Facebook there's a bunch of
idiots and [__] imagine if he just
bought that stock back then yeah that
was pretty sick move right coinbase
dumped and never came
back have you been paying attention he
doesn't pay attention ever he doesn't
pay attention no did the coinbase come
back it didn't like come all the way
back to the alltime high just wait till
this year but it bounced shots he sick
man boun off think's do uh so everyone
who's wondering what's a bitcoin ETF
right it's an exchang traded fund right
so you're you're able to to purchase uh
Bitcoin without actually owning a
Bitcoin right you're buying it through
someone else who's basically in custody
of the Bitcoin and you're able to be
part of the price action of a Bitcoin
which also minimizes your fees correct
well you also pay fees though
minimizes yeah well according to
who cuz bro well definitely not gr scale
they charge the highest ones but like
Fidelity is cheaper stuff like that well
they're all competing with each other to
knock the fees down though that's a fact
that's a fact that's a fact but you're
not owning the underlying asset right
someone else is so like a lot of the
crypto community and if I didn't say
this then bu of my buddies would give me
[__] so I have to say this [__] okay if
it's not your keys it's not your crypto
if you don't hold Bitcoin yourself you
don't actually hold Bitcoin and like
buying this ETF Bitcoin is not like
buying a Bitcoin or part of a Bitcoin
but the people that want to buy it I
don't think they even care about that
cuz I think the biggest so I feel like
there's different demographics right so
there's people that want to custody
their own Bitcoin but then there's also
other people like the older folks that
don't trust any of this [__] they want
to get in on the app action and so once
something is like SEC approved there's
all these rules and policies that
protect it kind of like how I think it
was like there's a stigma that gets
removed yeah and like FDIC is insured up
to 250k I think SEC like your assets is
up to 500k or something so now they can
get 500k potentially worth of bitcoin
without having to own actual Bitcoin and
hold custody by themselves and you can
now like go to your employer you got a
401k you got Fidelity account you can
now get Bitcoin exposure using that
right so all you people who stunned on
me try to stunt on me and [__] Bitcoin
is now an asset class you stupid
[__] if only instead of just
Clowning on us you just got in instead
can you imagine they would have been
making a lot of money with us but
they're busy trying to find why it all
sucks it's all such a scam and they're
still broke yeah still broke still
getting wrecked just like us still still
no profile pick yes still no pfp you got
no nft pfp you stupid
[__]
which Twitter just got rid of cuz
nobody's using that [__] so does this
how does this affect the average person
that doesn't even have any uh so now
when you go to a financial planner it
depends on where you go obviously but
like if you're talking to somebody who's
young yeah and affiliated with maybe
Fidelity or something like that this is
more of something they would maybe
recommend to you like hey like it's
almost like the mark cubin thing he's
been saying for a couple years now put
5% of your um portfolio into Bitcoin now
that's way more pervasive right more
people are out there saying things like
that it's now okay to say it's not like
crackpot [__] to say quote unquote
Elizabeth Warren saying it's all moneya
laundering [__] like all that okay
cool say whatever you want but shees
still hate it she still hates it she
always going to hate it right she's but
it's not like the dark web currency
anymore there's more legitimacy saying
the SEC approving the 11 spot Bitcoin
ETF is like the biggest mistake well
it's like I was texting you guys right
the [__] does she know she does have big
titties like Pelosi thank you thank you
I listen to Pelosi and she's just a
Native American what a unit of meas Peli
makes so much money too what does war
guy imagine if you had big old titties
and you made a lot of money that's
Pelosi you're [__] my queen you're my
queen ncy Pelosi yeah I'll give me those
mommy milkers all day yeah Warren
probably only got bees at best yeah nah
he's shaking them things around boy
Warren's got bees in a
bra but when they're hanging at least
sees my boy I want to see what she looks
like Elizabeth Warren she's Native
American yeah just picture like a
picture stereotypical you mean she's
native Amer blown Native American Google
waren Elizabeth waren and a pocah
costume
yeah sexy
sexy that's her oh yeah that's her you
found her yeah dude come on she's gotten
way better since the what does she know
about Bitcoin right there more what she
know about crypto yeah those look like
bees you know listen yeah what Pelosi
but everyone kind of shits on [__]
Bitcoin though like it seems like as far
as like some some like uh it's easy to
but everybody shits on everything that's
[__] new especially investing onse
yeah I do too everyone's too smart for
it right but I guess you can I mean it's
one of those things where I can see how
you could reasonably enter the space you
don't have to put all your money in
anything no for sure if you do you're
kind of a [__] anyway you're asking for
it yeah 100% like yeah earn it right
small to big try to turn a small amount
of money and do a big amount of money
earn it if you're any good at it you'll
see it in the multiples that's it it's
just so atypical to this particular
investment classes understanding of
Investments like a a semi steady stream
something like the pandemic's volatility
That's like [__] every other
Wednesday for like Bitcoin you know what
I'm saying like just seeing that thing
go up and down like that but this helps
with that because the more like for
example 21% of the world is into crypto
right now right so it's like it's a it's
a an actual Tech that's being adopted on
a global scale people unfortunately see
it as like oh well it's already everyone
knows about it nobody really cares or
whatever it's like dude nobody really
has exposure to it right so as something
like an ETF comes into to play more
people who are who have money in it it
actually becomes less volatile over time
but that's going to take them because
it's very new like stocks right exactly
so people were talking about the same
[__] with stocks but that was like so
long ago and all the advantages that we
have right now in the crypto game right
like all the ways that I'm able to turn
small amount of money into a big amount
of money every run this will lessen over
time as more things like this become
adopted on a global scale it's just how
it is right so so so the price will
become less volatile it just will as
more people hold it as more people hle
it it just will we won't see that the
crazy swings like we did no how does it
affect the value of woo for instance um
it's great for uh people who are selling
um the shovels and the pcks during the
Gold Rush right that's the whole game
behind the woo play yeah woo dude when I
found woo it it didn't have $1 to their
decks right woi not $1 and now it has
over 11 billion in volume wow and I
found it in a had it didn't that Dex
didn't even exist yet hadn't launched
yet right they just had their their
centralized exchange so but you have to
know how to look at this stuff it's
different I don't know how long my Edge
will last how long my advantage will
last I just try to play the game within
the cycle as much as I can so you're
saying you're edging right now Imaging
as hard as I can buddy as you know hey
you're on the come up dud I've been
[__] coming the whole time dude yeah
no we always going to come back look we
were always going to come back it was
always we were always going to do it
again I told everybody when we did our
Luna video I was like does anybody
really think I'm not going to do it
again I do it every time like it was
always going to happen but yeah you have
to have patience and you have to know
how to play the run so Luna wasn't the
right one dude it wasn't even a cool
name it wasn't a project wasn't that
cool dude you know I had doubts from at
the beginning I'll always remember Luna
She'll always be special that was
exciting it was fun we had a fun time
her Woo is what I love now okay Woo is
my guy and coi's been fun she needed to
exist in order for us to develop a
certain type of skin yeah but you know
you got to resent it you got to resent
it a little bit never ever let a good
failure go to waste right never out of
woo koogi Bitcoin ethereum which one do
you have the most in I have more of woo
than anything else wow but I I earned it
I earned it with kui I turned a small
amount of money I turned like $88,000
into like 60 something and I can
therefore print more big coin I beat
Bitcoin in the ratios that's my game I
do that every time I'm coming baby yeah
that's it it's all about the ratios Joe
does this cuz Joe does this ride every
time wait like what do you do right he
does the ride every time oh yeah I I
ride the alts when it's pumping and then
I move it into Bitcoin that's it and
that's that's the game I'm going to move
mine into Bitcoin so [__] hard dude
you're not going even know what's coming
to you I can't wait what do you what do
you have to say to all of the cardono
stands stands hey I I actually don't
hate card know I really don't but it's
funny it's funny it's funny it's funny
to clown on them it's funny to clown on
them yeah because of how much they
believe but what they're really trying
to do is unload their bags cuz they've
made a big
mistake that's
bold that's bold it was good in the
early stages it was sick in 2007 sure I
think a lot of the crypto influencers
bought it real real early and they
wanted to really pump it and it never
got to where they wanted it to get to so
now they're just holding bags it's
harder for it to pump because there's so
much of it right right like the token
Supply is so crazy high so you can't
double it's like Ripple exactly it's
like there's so much I know people don't
know that though it's like it's going to
go to $2 when yeah dude and they do this
new thing too cuz we got the ETF right
so they go well they're going to need
the banks are going to need Ripple to to
to to cross this bridge between Fiat and
crypto it's like they don't what the
[__] why would they need it they could
develop their own coin that's what
they'll do stupid they'll they'll be
Chase coin they'll be [__] Bank of
America coin they'll jump into a coin
they don't own all of it yeah why the
[__] would they go into Ripple have you
heard of um sock coin sock yeah like the
sock no like uh like sock on these
nuts we're coming baby shock Anthony
this guy's a little too masculine for me
coming all over the place this guy's on
fire I'm telling you I don't like how
masculine you I'm getting too burned
right now is there any hope for uh is
there any hope for crypto Zoo it's
looking really good it's looking real
good sick yeah I saw that um um what the
hell is his name he just did another
Cilla coffeezilla just did another thing
about oh was that the Logan Paul thing
yeah the Logan Paul thing [__] didn't a
lot of influencers get like sued for
promoting all that crypto dude like even
even like Steph Curry and all of them
were caught up in the giant lawsuit I
think maybe even Payton Manny or
something like that no Tom Brady not
Payton Tom Brady that's what it was Tom
for promoting a crypto promoting FTX
yeah but people like this [__] on on on
that and go that's part of why crypto is
like so corrupt and [__] it's like s
bankman freed gambled everyone's [__]
deposits like no different than a bank
using fractional Reserve banking right
could do that potentially with your
funds that could actually happen to you
right I mean Enron did that and they
were everyone talked big about them
exactly dude but people it's like oh but
because it's crypto connected that means
it's crypto that's bad it's like yeah
good luck dude simpletons I know that's
why they stay poor and they always will
yeah I stay poor because I made bad
choices but I know this information I
stay poor as a choice and that's why
you're You're A Cut Above even though
you're poor exactly exactly in your
face let's go dude but you're coming
come coin let's go hey that was a real
one just kidding news careful boys is a
brand just kidding news is the man of
smart people the people of just kidding
news careful boys they are very smart
just kidding news the number one podcast
in the
[Music]
world